hi my name is mouse I'm giving a talk
called minimalist piano forever but when
they say minimalist piano I'm
specifically talking about one piece of
music I'm talking about Erik Satie's
nisshin's number one and I wanted to
start with listening to it I'm not gonna
play the whole thing but I'll play the
first couple minutes because it's really
lovely and it's better than anything I
made
[Music]
[Music]
sorry that was a problem so millions is
a term that sati coined himself to
describe the genre of music he published
three notions initially in 1893 and then
three more were published posthumously
and it's not known for sure what the
name means there's a few theories all of
which are pretty plausible and the first
is that it's a reference to Virgil's
Aeneid lettuce the land which have an
appoint six floor appease the winds and
seek the notions Shore another theory is
that it's a reference to the Cretan word
for gnosis there were archaeological
sites related to this being excavated at
the time so it's in the popular
conscious and this is like the location
in which the mythological labyrinth with
Theseus and Ariadne and the Minotaur and
I think there's kind of a walking the
labyrinth field to his music so that
seems pretty credible and the theory
that I think is perhaps most likely is
that it's referenced in Gnosticism the
religious idea around the time when he
composed this music he was part of a
Rosicrucian sect a venerian Rosicrucian
sect and he had a falling out he wasn't
a bulgarian musically and he had a
falling out with a leader of the sect
and so he forms his own religion called
the Metropolitan Church of art of Jesus
the conductor of which he was the only
member and this is him in his ceremonial
robes whatever the case I really like
this piece of music and pretty much
instantly when I heard it I said I want
to listen to this forever
and but it seemed a little regressive to
just play it over and over so I thought
how can I make a version of it that just
doesn't end and it seemed like more club
chains were a good fit for that and this
explanation from Wikipedia a Markov
chain is a stochastic model describing a
sequence of possible events in which the
probability of each event depends only
on the state attained in the previous
event it's kind of jargony I'm gonna
walk through how I use a Markov chain a
couple times so bear with me but we can
essentially when we have a string of
symbols like words in a sentence or in
this case music notes on a staff we can
analyze it by saying every time a given
note appears what comes after it and
then what's the probability can have
this probabilistic model and say okay
given that I just played middle C what's
likely to come next so in this piece and
this is just a really simplified version
of just the treble cleff of partitions
and here are notes and there are some
notes that happen multiple times so for
example if we look at this first quarter
note C it can be followed by a
coordinate a flat or by this grace note
C so we could represent instead of as a
linear progression we could represent
this piece of music as a diagram with
loops and loops are great because loops
mean you can just keep going around the
loops forever and ever and ever which is
what I want and so there's a really good
blog post called generating music using
Markov chains by Alvin Lind and he has a
code sample where you can just give it a
music file at MIDI format it'll generate
a Markov chain and then produce new
music just going to note by note so
here's what it sounds like
[Music]
it doesn't sound anything like your
excit and linens a blog post by saying
it certainly doesn't sound very good and
it's still a very informative blog post
but what it reveals very quickly is that
Markov chains are really limited for
starters they don't have any sense of
context or place so if you have a piece
of music that has a strong sense of
progression that changes a lot like the
middle feels really different than the
end feels different than the beginning a
Markov chain is really gonna garble it
up because it'll take you know a note
that appears at the end and then jump
right back to the beginning and you'll
lose any sense of the spirit of the
piece and it doesn't consider any
structure so if there is a tendency to
like start a pattern and then end it in
a certain way you probably are gonna get
lost and never get back to where you
were about to go and it works really
well for simple structurally simple
linear things like so it works really
well for us for writing because we just
have one word after another but it gets
a little hairy with music like he could
imagine if we had a symphony where
there's a whole bunch of different
instruments all playing simultaneously
and they're interrelated it would be
incredibly difficult and possibly not
viable at all to represent that in a
Markov chain because it's just too much
interacting information so the one thing
that you can really control with a
Markov chain is how many symbols you
want to assess together so like we
talked about Markov chains being engrams
where n is the number of things like
number of words or number of notes and
clearly from the example I just played
and setting into one is not gonna work
for us and it sounds terrible so I want
to look at the music itself in order to
figure out how we can apply Markov
chains to it and I want to start by
talking about who eric sati was and he
was famously eccentric and he has a lot
of habits that show up in his life and
in his music that are really focused
around obsession maybe to the point of
sorry focused around repetition
to the point of obsessiveness he wore a
gray velvet suit every day here in the
nickname the velvet gentleman and he
never let anyone into his home but after
he died it was people went in and they
found I mean partly that it was at
squalor but also he had two pianos
stacked on top of each other and the
bottom one he played and the top one was
just stuffed full of unsent letters and
he wasn't very successful financially
early in his career and so he moved out
of Paris into a suburb and every day
because he still want to be part of
Paris culture he would walk two hours
from where he lived into Paris and he
would stop along cafes in the along the
way it so the apparently he carried a
hammer to protect himself I don't think
he ever had to use it but I like to
think that we can really see in his
music and in the way that he lived his
life that perhaps like maybe maybe in
some ways it was obsessive in a bad way
but other ways I think that he found
beauty and this really intense
repetition of walking two hours in two
hours back every single day taking these
same paths and I think in the piece just
in the little bit that I played of no
see ends you can see that repetition
it's really taken to the extreme in his
piece called vexations which wasn't
discovered until after his death you
can't read it here because it's hard to
read and also in French but it says at
the top in order to play the theme 840
times in succession it would be
advisable to prepare oneself beforehand
and then the deepest silence by serious
and mobilities this so he died in the
1920s and this was first performed in
1963 it was staged by John Cage who was
a huge fan of satis work and the
performance took more than 18 hours I've
heard that other performances
performances have been done in like a
marathon format swapping musicians out
and have taken like 35 hours and the
people who have played this piece have
said that it gets them into like a may
be scary altered state it's a really
intense piece of music Society was an
artist in other ways besides
to composer this is a self-portrait that
he drew imagining a bust of himself he
was also a writer he wrote poems and
accompaniments to his music but he
strictly forbid that they ever be read
while the music's played he also this is
my favorite Eric's at effect when his
big hobby was that he would draw
pictures of imaginary buildings and he
would write little fanciful descriptions
of them and he had just filing cabinet
drawers stuffed full of these like
excuse me he had tons and tons of these
and sometimes he would file he would
place newspaper ads and advertising them
for rent this is one strange grandiose
feudal castle 12th century abandoned
built in 1113 in one night by the
devil's son for his pretty mistress deep
in great ancient distant woods rivers
ponds lovely meadows all enclosed in
great long walls etc I really wish I'd
found one of those ads just late
browsing the newspaper one day so
suffice to say he had his own creative
vision that was really different than
everybody else's and his style of music
was really avant-garde and really
experimental and I like to think that
although he certainly wasn't designing
like algorithm music in the way that we
think of it and he wasn't you know it
was 1800s he wasn't composing for the
Babbage engine I think that the way in
which he's playful with how music is
structured is really conducive to being
playful with the way music is structured
using algorithms and there's I think a
fair bit of music that is based on a
playful computer music based on Eric
settee because of that he
he collaborated with the Dadaist
movement he met Tristan Tzara this is a
piece that he did with man-ray it's
called the gift memory also took some of
the more famous portraits of him he
composed a ballet called the parade that
was staged by Picasso
so certainly avant-garde his music is
minimalist he rejected the idea of
progression and he broke pieces that
really lack ornamentation and flourished
they're really simple and that makes
them really beautiful and it also makes
them possible to put into a Markov chain
because he's not composing he often just
composed for piano and not for 30
instruments so it makes it actually
viable with this algorithm he's famous
speaking of simplicity for composing
what he called furniture music like
which is basically background music and
there's a story that I really liked that
when his furniture music debuted
everyone in the audience when the
musicians started playing all paid
attention and he ran around through the
audience begging them to go back to
their conversations
but let's go back to Michigan's number
one the piece I actually want to look at
and just break down the sheet music and
I tried to write a description of how to
read sheet music in case in all of you
know how but it turned out that I would
take the whole time so just bear with me
I'll try to keep it simple so this is
written in free time which means it's
not divided into measures it's not like
in 4/4 3/4 but and you'll have to like
set your purest instincts aside if we
break it down we can kind of imagine
that it's in four beat measures and the
notes will fall into those categories
and in that while it's a little and
untrue to his vision helps us actually
analyze it so let's look at the first
four beats
that's what sounds like and this four
beats appears throughout the piece of
music and what comes next is one of five
things there's this group for this group
there's two more I'm not going to keep
playing
this is an AP group it's just in the
actual code I treated it as 2 for B
groups but it's always repeated in this
8 beat chunk and there's two more I'm
not gonna keep playing them so we could
represent this like we did earlier as a
kind of flowchart we have our first
beats in the middle and then what can
follow it I've numbered the arrows to
indicate how often that transition
happens so in each case there's two of
this blue group there's two Orange
there's two yellow etc and that will
allow us to calculate the actual
probability that given whatever group
you're at it'll go to the next one so
let's look again at the second blue
group it's always followed again by the
first group same with orange same with
teal so these are all perfect loops the
purple group however it can go back to
where it started or it can go to this
new dark green group and our yellow
group can go to this new light green
group so our flowcharts getting more
interesting now can do something besides
just go in circles and what's handy is
that I've introduced these two new
groups of repeating notes they happen a
lot so we've actually covered a whole
lot of the sheet music just with this
and if you'll notice there's the last
measure which ends the piece which I'm
just gonna pretend doesn't exist because
I don't want to end the piece and and
then there's these four gaps and there's
16 beats long and what's handy is
they're all the same so if we add that
to our flow chart we've mapped the
entire piece of music and it's really
structurally you can see how
structurally simple it is so I'm going
to convert these numbers that I have of
like how many times something goes from
one group to another into actual
probabilities and this is really handy
because if you've ever written a
function that does a weighted random it
really is a lot easier if you have
probabilities add up to 1 another thing
that'll make this easier to work with on
a computer is having it not look like
this this is I think for me easier to
visually understand but I would balk at
trying to store this as a data structure
so we can do is make a probability table
on the top you're saying ok given that
we start with this set of notes this
measure what's the probability that'll
be followed by the measures on the side
and we can just look here and copy over
these probabilities and I think I'll
leave it to your imagination to think
how you could represent this as a data
structure the one thing that you're
probably going to get stuck on with your
data structure is putting colored
screenshots of sheet music in as
dictionary keys
but that's where MIDI comes in we don't
actually want to have a computer program
analyze the sheet music itself at least
I don't I think it's a hassle especially
when the MIDI format exists it was
standardized in 1983 it's called the
musical instrument digital interface and
it's really big and really useful and
I'm only using a really small amount of
it so it's a communication standard for
music data and it's also a file format
and it's a way to control a physical
electronic musical instrument from your
computer so you could write an algorithm
that plugs into your synthesizer and
actually plays your synthesizer or you
can use it to record the output of the
physical electronic instrument so you
could play electric guitar that's
plugged into your computer and have the
output of you playing turn into computer
data but I'm really just interested in
MIDI files and they're made up of MIDI
messages and a message is an 8-bit
status byte plus one or two data bytes
there's two general kinds system
messages which apply to the entire MIDI
file like syncing the clock and plenty
of others that I won't talk about and
also channel messages pardon me
so a MIDI has 16 channels and these are
essentially streams that run
simultaneously so you could imagine like
if you had three different instruments
you put them on three different channels
and they would all play simultaneously
sleep and there's two messages that are
relevant here note on which is like
press the piano key and note off which
is lift your finger off it these are
held voice messages and they have four
pieces of data the channel notation
velocity and time the channel like I
just described it's a simultaneous
string with music for this since we just
have treble and bass clefts and make
sense to make those our two channels you
can imagine you know we're playing these
simultaneously so the notation is what
note is being played MIDI has numbers so
for example this is MIDI note 41 or its
fourth octave F and you can just convert
pretty simply between that or you can
also play it use them convert to like
frequencies and play frequency but I
want it to sound like a piano velocity
is like how hard you hit the key or just
how loud it is in our music notation
here it says to play in piano or quietly
and time is the duration that you wait
before starting a message so it's kind
of it's like the how long the message
takes
here's the MIDI output for the first
four beats of our on the treble clef
you may notice right away that it only
has no on and not note off and I decided
to just be like radically honest because
this is the output that I got when I was
analyzing my MIDI file I don't know if
it was a weirdness in hell the MIDI was
encoded or how am i Python library read
it but instead of turning the nose off
it just sets their velocity or volume to
zero so this is what I actually work
with so we can see the first if you're
reading sheet music the first thing that
happens is a rest and that's represented
by the time the wait time of 40 for 80
milliseconds and then we have a note
that starts playing it plays for two
hundred thirty nine milliseconds and
then it stops etc it's a little more
complicated in the bass clef because we
have a whole note which plays while
other notes are being played so you can
see the first note on message
starts playing this whole note and then
a whole bunch of other things happen it
plays these chords and you can see they
have the time of zero which means
they're simultaneous and then and then
after all this happens the notice turned
off so if you want to look at how long a
single note is played you have to kind
of look ahead and count up all the time
duration intervals that happen until
that notice turned off which is just
something to keep in mind so back to our
beautiful flow chart let's just like use
the power of our imaginations and stay
instead of little colorful sheet music
these are midi messages and the same
thing in our flip in our probability
table these are all just sets of stored
MIDI messages so now that we have this
table we can start picking things let's
start at the beginning and then ran
weighted randomly select what's gonna
happen next
there we go and now there's only one
option in this column
it's our probability one so we're
definitely going to pick that and add
that to our chain and we can just keep
doing this forever but that doesn't
actually make any noise
because MIDI just tells you a lot of
information about the music it doesn't
actually it's not like an mp3 it doesn't
play yeah so we can you can play it a
lot of different ways you can play it
using frequencies or because I wanted to
sound like an actual piano I'm gonna use
what's called a sound font which is just
a fancy way of saying it's a dictionary
that associates the name of the note or
the MIDI number to an mp3 file that has
the sound of that piano note being hit
what's cool about a sound font is that
you can really quickly swap them out so
I could go from playing piano to playing
cello to playing like cats yowling to my
heart's content and for anything that
you can imagine and record you can put
in a sound file and I want to do this in
the browser so I use something very
handy html5 audio elements as you can
see it's really simple this is called
audio you can give a source so it
actually has something to play and you
can give it a controls attribute which
will put
and this little nice interface it looks
a little different in every browser in
the UI automatically or you can control
it using JavaScript which is what I
wanted to do so if you select the Dom
element it has built in a play function
in a pause function in a current time
function which lets you seek within the
file it doesn't have a stop function but
you can replicate that by pausing it and
then use setting current time back to
zero so that's actually we kind of have
everything we need in order to play
music in the browser so I'm going to
demonstrate what it sounds like
[Music]
so we're giving their I'm not totally
happy with it right now
because it's being played by a website
and not a person and when websites play
music particularly piano music they
don't or they always play it perfectly
exactly consistently so if you tell it
to go at this tempo it's gonna go at
that tempo and they take the music
completely literally they're never going
to make a you know executive creative
decision about how the piece should be
played they also because MIDI has 16
channels your computer essentially has
16 arms and each of those arms has like
question mark number of fingers maybe 88
fingers and so I don't know like picture
that is you go to sleep tonight and also
as you might have realized it's not
actually physically playing the piano
it's playing an mp3 file and that's
different that real piano humans on the
other hand are not perfect even if
you're trying to play a really regular
tempo you're gonna play it a little
irregularly humans can make interpretive
decisions about how things should be
played generally speaking humans only
have up to two arms and five fingers per
hand so that's a limitation on what you
can physically play on a piano also
people can play real pianos it's a great
ability and were united by our plink ooh
plink noises
so let's apply what we just learned
about humans versus websites to this the
very start of this piece of music I want
you to if you play piano at all bear
with me we're going to imagine we play
this
so first let's hit this bottom note with
our one hand we're going to hold that
for four beats and at the same time
we're gonna play what's on the treble
clef and then also with our third arm
we're gonna play what's on the bass clef
and it's not going to work and that's
why it's nice to be a human being
because we have to problem-solve and
generally when people play this what
they're doing is they're using the
sustain pedal and so that means that
when you press a key and then release it
the mute the sound keeps playing and
that lets you just press that whole note
and release it and then go on and do the
rest of the piece while that in place
but the sustain pedal doesn't just
affect one note it affects every note
and so that changes the whole way in
which this piece sounds it has just a
different vibe because everything is a
little bit elongated and stretched
together and when a computer plays it
it's just going to use three arms so
it's gonna sound different it's not
gonna have quite the same vibe and I
haven't I don't think I've totally
solved this if you have figured out how
to make websites have a sustain pedal I
don't know let me know but we can still
make it sound a little better than it
does the biggest thing that you need to
do is not just stop an audio clip like I
did when I was playing the original
piece of music earlier it sounds
terrible when you just cut a piece of
music off or it kind of note off I don't
know how well you can hear it in this
room but certainly like if you're
listening to in headphones
it sounds really odd like on the grace
notes when they just stop and if you
don't do anything fancy I just literally
decrease the volume rather than setting
it straight to zero it makes a huge
difference and then I want to add some
variation some irregularity in each note
and also just some variation throughout
the piece and how it's played because a
real pianist would have a sense of like
phrasing and change throughout the piece
I want these to be small because I don't
want to simulate like if I actually
played it which would be terrible
because I'm not a good piano
I want to simulate heard someone hooting
after the play piano and then also the
last thing I do is just make the notes
last a little longer to give it that
like a legato feel where the notes blend
together so here's a demo of that and it
just sounds a little more natural than
it did before the other thing you may
have noticed is that I'm drawing the
sheet music I enjoy that I think it adds
a lot to the feel and I'm not really
going to talk in detail about how I did
this because I just use a library called
vex flow and I think it's vex flow comm
it's great basically you just tell it
what you want it to render in their
specific format and then it makes an SVG
of that so worth checking out but I'm
not gonna write their documentation for
them and so it just renders the four
beat measures just before they're played
and now the very final less thing that
we haven't talked about is Erik Satie
wrote the most amazing expression
markings in music this is the spot where
the composer tells you how you should
play the piece of music often it's
something like slowly or quickly early
brightly it just gives you a sense of
what it's supposed to sound like Bisutti
wrote really interesting ones
the first one we see the first one we
see in the first missions is slowly
which seems very normal but we get into
so as to obtain a whole open your head
and provide yourself with clairvoyance
these are all taken from the three
notions but throughout his work he just
has the most wonderful expression
markings that and I think he does a
really good job with having them be
absurd but still actually give you an
idea of how to play the piece of music
and I wanted to have this carry through
when I made him an infinite version I
wanted I didn't want to just like
recycle his butt and I also want to stay
kind of within the mood and the sense of
the expression mark is he made so I just
used like very simple kind of mad lead
style word-lists to generate new
expression markings have questions don't
consider your body be healthfully
translucent have ill intent with the
whole this was actually made absolute
favorite part of the whole project even
though it's a relatively small part and
it's the last part that's that's pretty
much what I did
[Music]
and I think I have time for questions
yeah I have plenty of time for questions
five ten minutes so I think we're gonna
have someone come around with a mic and
obviously feel free to come find me
after my talk or hit me up on email or
um I have you considered instead of
using the sound font actually bill the
innocent they're using the web audio
system to build this synthesizer or
something to get more of that variation
that you were kind of looking for in the
audio I've considered it and I haven't
really tried it I would like to and I
think it'd be fun to have a little bit
more custom ability and what the
audience like like I was saying it would
be cool to have like a cat yowling
version of no scans and I just didn't
really get to that this was sort of a
weekend project and I really wanted my
like baseline to be an acoustic piano
and I figured the easiest quickest way
to get the sound of acoustic piano was
to just play back in acoustic piano
thanks for the talk do you have any
recommendations about autobiographical
information for city like biographical
sources because his life sounds amazing
and I actually have with me he wrote a
lot and there's a lot of there's a
couple books of his writing and I have
one called a mammals notebook which I
have with me if you want to look at it
has a lot of his and little newspaper
clippings and hit the building psyche
tree which I wasn't able to find online
so definitely just like go to the
primary source and read his own writing
I haven't read any biographies of him
but I know they exist and they're
probably lovely how well do you think
that this would translate to other
minimalist pieces like Jim hoppitty have
you experimented with or just with first
no cm I've only experimented with the
first miss yeah and that's like my
number-one like next to do is to try
maybe the second miss yen it definitely
I took a very hands-on and like
labor-intensive approach to this like I
really I was actually taking a piano
class at the time and I was trying to
play this for a recital
so I was really like super heavily
involved in this piece of music which is
why I was able to like break it down
pretty readily so yeah I think it's
possible but it would definitely be kind
of on a case-by-case basis have you
hello the question was have I considered
generating C score sounds I don't know
what that is
sorry so no hi so what are the chances
that he use a Markov chain for to
generate this like this you know it
sounds similar yeah I mean it's not
outside the realm of possibility
definitely you see like John Cage
compositions that are really like
basically just Markov chains that he's
written down in music form certainly
that was like later in time but I
certainly yeah I wouldn't rule out the
possibility that satti really was using
kind of algorithmic processes to
generate his music but I don't know I
don't that would be totally speculation
hi even though you change the delays for
the starting point did you just open the
audio into a program and see the the
timing in between notes oh yeah I
shouldn't talk about that I use just
JavaScript for window time out events to
trigger when the notes are played so but
how did you how did you find the delays
in between the notes originally yeah so
I got a MIDI file that was generated
from sheet music and there's a website
and a piece of software called musescore
and it lets you it's intended for
editing sheet music and somebody has
just transcribed the piece of music in
DM you score and then that piece of
software will produce an algorithmic
they generated MIDI file based on it so
I had a MIDI file to work with it had
all of the delays that were encoded
based on the sheet music to tell her hi
is
any possible application to Stockhausen
for example for the Markov chains I
don't know but I'm gonna say yes I don't
know I don't know what that is I was
just wondering if there's enough data to
train a model to generate variations on
the phrases that he used in in kind of
the lookup table I'm sorry can you
repeat the question I was wondering if
there was enough data to like to train a
model to generate kind of musical
variations on each individual phrase you
were using maybe there's like I mean if
we remember that floater I made there
really isn't that much data within the
piece of music it's really really simple
I think that if you wanted to generate
new Eric's Lahti music that wasn't just
like reconfigurations of what he already
wrote it would probably be more than
just one of his compositions I do think
it's possible and it would be a task for
something more clever than a Markov
chain would it be difficult for you to
just press play for the rest of your Q&A
time
[Applause]
yeah yes oh maybe I don't have internet
I may have to play the bad version
I shouldn't have refreshed I made a
mistake ok we're gonna we're gonna
listen to not quite as good version any
other questions
[Music]
yes the question is should we be having
conversations with the answer is yes
please don't pay attention to music I
[Music]
have a question this seems like it could
be used in applications that have to do
with hoop up improvised music like I
imagined with a much more complex and
require like a bigger library of phrases
or in the context of jazz like licks or
something but it seems like this could
have applications to generate but
improvised melodies and stuff would be
very interesting do you know about other
people that are doing similar kinds of
things or like that the body of work in
this area that might be applicable for
that yeah I don't have the deep amount
of knowledge about this but I know that
a pretty common way that markup chains
are used to music is to like analyze
jazz improvisation and jazz music so
that's this definitely really applicable
there
[Music]
um which I don't know Oh would you like
to like you view of all of this you
sometimes expressions to form the way
that the notes are played definitely my
list of things I'd like to do is like be
able to swap out the sound fonts for
other things or to use synthesized audio
to have a little bit more correlation
between the expression and the music and
be more thoughtful about how it's how
the phrasing works in terms of like
tempo and dynamic and also just change
where I put the changes in dynamic I
think they're not very well placed right
now yes we can do one more
yeah I'm glad you press the play button
here because I work to this piece and
when it does something different from
what I'm expecting
I sense a joke it's like oh that's funny
that's not how it's supposed to go and
somehow that's a little joke then it
happens to get it so hoho they're really
trying to trick me do you get that same
impulse and did you ever play this for
your piano instructor and see what their
reaction is no I ended up dropping a
piano class so but in another hair
settee fact he actually failed out of
conservatory and was considered an
atrocious student a terrible pianist by
his instructors he later went back and
did very well but I guess I'm good
company in that I didn't finish my piano
class I do think that you bring up a
good point which is that there's like a
really fun playfulness to his music and
to all of his compositions like his
writings are all really funny and like
clearly not always meant to be taken
literally and I sort of can never tell
when he's joking them any serious which
I really appreciate and I think that
shows through this music yeah and they
that's all thank you so much
[Applause]